trains on that side but it can also get
to the rim and a boy the Laura Johnson
water stain on the floor sign Dillon
Brooks short country Westbrook with his
down down the rim toward the bucket
makes back-to-back baskets
shan-dro Stefan back in coming up on
Terra's Ferguson his check dent was
still London eight minutes remaining in
the first half solvers springing into
them off the street from Davis snow was
too happy to tell you anything cool Paul
George out right now let's take them out
of the ballgame
[Music]
that's what one of the single biggest
depression things about the improvement
in his game this years he's got so much
better at it before curling off that
screen things rusted to rebound Diaz
Clemente pulling a lot of pressure on
the transition team decks of the
Grizzlies
they just shown under pressure PI R at
time 3 Blount buckets although they are
3 of 12 overall will be on the alert
tonight he first the corner of the three
noted
he was so slow picked up collisions
particularly without this big pedal
that's what passes pensions the edges
Charles hoped it was going crazy
well he was yeah 35 rebounder with Ed
[Music]
[Applause]
Davis with you Chesapeake arena over
with Russell Westbrook I did Corey
Brewer the
problems also because new tourism
laughs it's a little bit short I hope
the United States is working on the
pitch in 2012
George checking's Dillon Brooks you
couldn't average a triple-double even
once
Russell is all the birds of doing it for
the second year and he is now
clock winding down Kobi Simmons
by George with the rhythm let's go
faster right back / - treatment on to
the game is 1970 his - off his career
high of 9 made threes nice defense at
the rim by Adams chomp one advantage for
the clutter rose just in size 7 minutes
remaining in regulation marShon Brooks
is due to see Bill was the era started a
lot of the ball
[Applause]
where the Grizzlies soccer ball